STEVEN ROTHSTEIN: Welcome.
Welcome to everyone, this
first night after last night.
I was so--
[LAUGHTER]
We are so thrilled that
all of you are here.
My name is Steve Rothstein.
I'm the executive director of
the John F. Kennedy Library
Foundation.
And on behalf of all of
the library employees,
and the foundation
employees, we are thrilled.
And we're so thrilled
actually, not just are you
filled this room, but there's
an overflow room that's filled.
And there are many
people watching online.
So we're thrilled
that all of you
are here for this special
guest and this special evening.
Before I introduce them, there
are a few other quick things
I do want to say.
First, I want to
thank our sponsors,
the Bank of America,
the Lowell Institute,
and our media sponsors, the
Boston Globe, Xfinity, WBUR
is here.
And tonight we also
want to recognize
Frank Islam and Debbie
Driesman who's here,
and Boston Magazine.
So join me to thank all of them.
[APPLAUSE]
Our amazing host and guests
are going to speak for a bit.
And then there'll be a chance
for question and answers.
Then if you're interested,
there are two microphones
in the aisles.
Line up at that time.
And Robin will tell
you when that is.
If you're in the
overflow room, our team
can help you come on in
here and get in line as well
for those questions.
At the end, Doris Kearns
Goodwin has graciously
agreed to sign books.
They are also, if you
don't already have them,
they're available
in the bookstore.
And there'll be a line there.
So if you're interested
in the books,
you can go out my
left, your right.
If you're not, then you go out
that way just to keep it going.
I also want to say, for those
who haven't read this yet,
this is a brilliant,
brilliant piece of work.
One of things I try to
do is read all the books
from our authors who come here.
And this one was
just incredible.
To take these four
presidents and weave
through elements of their
lives is just majestic.
But The New York Times, when
they were talking about this,
they said quote,
"We can only hope
that a few of
Goodwin's many readers
will find in her subject
examples, a margin
of inspiration and resolve to
steer the country to a better
place."
end quote.
I also want to recognize
in the audience,
and I'm not sure where
they are, but we have--
one of the four
presidents this is about
is, Theodore Roosevelt.
That Theodore Roosevelt's
great grandson and his
son is with us tonight.
So we're thrilled that
they're with us tonight.
[APPLAUSE]
You know, when you do
these kind of events
and you sometimes say someone
needs no introduction, well,
literally, if you looked in
a dictionary Doris Kearns
Goodwin's picture would be there
in the need no introduction.
So having realizing
that, I am going
to say a little bit about this
Pulitzer Prize winning New York
Times best seller author.
This is her seventh
book and it draws
on her five decades of amazing
scholarship that she's done.
And her awards and
recognitions, I'm
not going to list them
all because we have
an important forum to get to.
But a few of them include
a Pulitzer Prize for a book
on FDR, the best selling memoir
on Fitzgerald and Kennedy,
which became a mini
series, a Carnegie medal,
working with Steven
Spielberg on Lincoln, which
was so much based on her
writings, the Frankel
prize, the New England book
prize, and so much more.
Speaking of award
winning Robin Young
has won so many
distinguished awards
during her 25
years in journalism
both at PUR and at
NPR Here and Now.
She's won a Peabody
and several Emmys.
She has previously done work
with NBC and CBS and the Today
show.
Again, it's a long list.
So join, me when I
say it's a real honor
to have both of these
women here tonight.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ROBIN YOUNG: So, there was
nothing going on today.
I just got out of the
studio a few minutes ago
and raced over here because we
had some extraordinary press
conferences today we're
going to talk about.
I just want to make one note.
I just shrink and wince
when anything I've done
is mentioned next to my fellow
New Yorker here, Doris Kearns
Goodwin.
But I have to change
the website, Steve.
Because I think I
wrote that 25 years
in broadcasting 15 years ago.
I kind of like it.
Doris, we spoke about
your extraordinary book
a couple of months ago at your
beautiful home in Concord.
And at the time, I mean, who's
read the book so we know.
Plenty of people have read it.
Oh, but plenty are
still in for a treat.
And what you do
throughout the book
is talk about the things
that shape these four
extraordinary leaders, LBJ, FDR,
Teddy Roosevelt, and Lincoln.
And they included things like
suffering loss, but being
burnished by it,
humility, an ability
to have empathy for others.
And the list goes
on, controlling
impulses of negative emotions.
And we have a president
today, who I mean,
I'm going to say out loud
what he kind of said today
in his press comments,
does none of these things,
does not acknowledge
mistakes or losses.
Today he said that
the midterms were
complete victory,
almost complete
victory for the Republicans.
They did quite well but
not a complete victory.
The empathy, he was asked
during the press conference
today about mentioning a
caravan that's 800 miles away
and a, divisive language, and
he literally said, well, we won.
He and his supporters
would say, hogwash.
My way is working.
His way is not this
way and it is working.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: Whoa.
You know I think it's
working in the short term.
Because what he was able
to do during the election
and then it stayed true in
the people who supported him
this time is to
speak to people who
had felt much like
the people felt
at the turn of the 20th century,
that they'd been left out
of the America that is here
today, and worried about where
the America is going.
I mean at the turn
of the 20th century
it was so much of an echo
to what's happening now.
The Industrial
Revolution had shaken up
the economy much
like tech revolution
and globalization
have done today.
For the first
time, there's a gap
between the rich and the poor.
The working class feel cut off
from the plenty of the country.
There's a fear of immigration.
And there's a sense in the
turn of the 20th century
that a revolution was coming.
But we had a leader
then in Teddy Roosevelt,
who was able to channel
that populist emotion, which
was anti-immigrant, anti-elite,
into reform, the Square
Deal for the rich and
the poor, the wage
worker and the capitalist.
And what's happened
with President Trump
is he got those people to feel
that he was on their side.
And the polarization in this
country is really at a height,
I mean longer than
in my lifetime.
I mean, maybe not as long as
in the lifetime of the people
that I've lived with, because
it's not as bad as the 1850s.
And I think it's
important for people
to feel, everybody
keeps asking me,
are these the worst of times?
And they feel like an
unmoored time right
now, because of the lack of a
discernible political truth,
because of lies and fake news
and a fight with the press that
is unprecedented, the
enemy of the people,
even as this press
conference happened today.
But we have lived through
worse times before.
And I think it's important
to get that perspective,
so that we don't feel like we
can't get out of these times.
I mean, if you lived
with Lincoln at the time
when he comes into
office in 1861,
there's going to be
a civil war that will
kill more than 600,000 people.
He never thought,
he said, he could
have lived through the
anxiety if he had known
what would be ahead of time.
And Teddy Roosevelt's time
was even more tumultuous
than this one is for
some of the same reasons.
And the early days of the
Depression, if you're there
and you're not sure
that the banks are even
going to continue, because
they've taken your money
and put it in the stock market.
And some of them have money
but they don't believe they do.
So there's a sense of not being
able to deal with your money.
There's loss of jobs and
people who are hungry.
And yet we got through that.
And even when LBJ comes in,
it's the assassination of JFK,
and there's not a clear idea
of where it's coming from.
So the country was in shock.
And yet we had the
right leaders and we
had citizens who
were awakened, who
became part of the
struggle, which
is what is the hopeful thing
to me about this election
yesterday.
In each one of the
cases that I've studied,
it was the citizens who
created a movement that allowed
the leaders to go forward.
The antislavery
movement, Lincoln said,
was more important
than what he did.
Without them.
He couldn't have done it.
The progressive movement
was essential for both Teddy
and Franklin and the civil
rights movement for LBJ.
We saw an awakening yesterday.
We saw people standing
on long lines.
We saw hosts of new
women coming into office
for the first time who had not
been in public life before.
[APPLAUSE]
We all saw a host of veterans
coming into office too.
And I think what that means
is that somethings, there's
a fever that has to be
broken and something's
been really wrong in Washington
for a long period of time.
And people coming
into public life now
means they still
believe in politics.
They still believe that politics
can be as JFK wanted it to be,
an honorable profession, so
that's a really good sign.
So I think as polarizing as the
election was and how it still
is going to produce a
divided House and a Senate,
if the citizens are awakened
and if the people are
the ultimate check on what's
going on right now, if they
exercise their power, not just
to vote but to be citizens that
are active instead
of spectators,
we're going to be OK.
ROBIN YOUNG: Well, and I'm
glad you mentioned the word
compassion and people
having genuine fear.
Because having been
out in places outside
of Massachusetts, we
are in a blue bubble.
There are people who
are genuinely afraid.
They feel that the world
is passing them by.
The Progressive
Movement has been--
[AUDIO OUT]
I mention sometimes-- refer
back to that 25 plus 15 years.
You know I'll mention to
my younger colleagues,
they'll talk about how awful
things are and I'll say,
are you kidding me?
Never would have
thought of recycling.
We had to fly on airplanes
where you die of cancer just
from the smoking
that was happening.
It never would've occurred to
women to be in broadcasting.
That's just a very
small list, you know.
So there has been
so much change.
And there are people
who are genuinely very
frightened by that.
There are also
deplorables, hate mongers,
who, are hearing the
words of the president.
And this isn't just
me saying this,
these are right wing
websites saying,
that after hearing some
words from the president
about sending troops to
the border and an invasion
of immigrants, they
are saying things
like that recent ad, that was
complete fear mongering, so
bad that Fox News had to pull
the ad, the Willie Horton-esque
ad.
The right wing
websites while crowing
about how we couldn't have
written better ourselves
and couldn't have done
this better ourselves.
So that is happening.
Frightening time
for a lot of people.
So let's go through some
of these leadership things.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN:
They're going to help us
if we remember these guys.
They'll give us perspective.
They'll show us that--
ROBIN YOUNG: These guys,
you mean these presidents.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: My guys.
ROBIN YOUNG: She refers
to them as her guys.
They have rooms in her home.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: They do.
ROBIN YOUNG: This
is Teddy's room.
Let's talk about the
guys, because these people
who are so afraid, many of
them that I've spoken to,
they just see President
Trump's boisterousness,
as they would call it, as
Teddy Roosevelt. You know,
why isn't it the same?
Why isn't it the
same as somebody
who was slightly
imperialistic for a while,
and kind of carried that
big-- why isn't it the same?
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN:
Well, I think in some ways
if we needed somebody
to come back today
to take on President
Trump, it would
be Teddy Roosevelt. I mean
he had that fiery spirit.
He understood how to have
short phrases, so that he'd
be great with
Twitter I think, you
know speak softly, speak
softly and carry a big stick.
Don't hit until you have
to and then hit hard.
You know, even
gave Maxwell House
the slogan, good to
the very last drop,
he could command attention.
He'd be the center of
colorful attention.
I mean he liked that as well
as President Trump does.
They said about him that he--
his daughter actually
said about him
that he wanted to be
the baby at the baptism
and the bride at the wedding
and the corpse at the funeral.
However, there's
huge differences.
I mean the first difference is
humility, the quality that we
mentioned, which
means the ability
to acknowledge errors and
learn from your mistakes.
When he was in the
state legislature,
he admittedly said he
grew a swelled head.
At first he was so
blistering in his language
against his opponents,
he would pound his desk
and he would say terrible
things about them.
And he made headlines all
around New York State.
And then he realized
he couldn't get
anything done because
the Democrats wouldn't
listen to him.
And even his fellow
Republicans were
upset with the kind of
language that he was using.
So he said, I had
a swelled head.
I rose like a rocket.
I came down like a rocket.
And he learned to
soften his language
and to compromise
and to collaborate.
He also developed
something that I'm
afraid President Trump,
I haven't seen develop,
which was empathy.
I mean he acknowledged that when
he first went into politics,
it wasn't to help other people,
that it was just an adventure.
He wanted to go into politics.
But then as he went through
the political experience,
and he went into
decrepit tenements
and he was a police
commissioner,
he saw what the slums
were like at night,
and he saw child labor.
He said, I began to feel what
a fellow feeling, he said.
I had fellow feeling that may
have been conscious at first,
but then became real.
And I wanted to do things
to make things better.
ROBIN YOUNG: Could
you expound on this?
He was police commissioner
in New York at a time
when, they were
called tenements,
and they were a horror.
What did he see what
are some of the things
that he saw that shocked him?
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN:
Well amazingly,
what happened is
he decided that he
had to see whether the
policemen were doing their job.
Because the police
department was pretty corrupt
at that time.
The political bosses were
making deals with them.
And some of the
policemen were very good
and others were corrupt.
So he want to see who
was doing their job.
So between midnight and
5:00 AM, he put on a coat.
He put on a slouch
hat and he went
wandering through the streets.
And they couldn't
recognize him he thought.
And they didn't actually.
At a certain point, he comes on
a policeman who was with a girl
and he's not doing his duty.
And so it says to him,
what are you doing?
The guy says, what's
it to you, guy?
You know he doesn't know.
The other guy next to him says,
don't you see who that is?
And then there were
cartoons all over the place
of policemen terrified
of big teeth and glasses.
But what he saw was when
he saw the slums at night,
he saw the lack of light.
He saw the stairwells
that you couldn't get up.
And you begin to feel then, when
you do that, and then of course
he became a soldier in
the Spanish American War.
So he's with his
fellow soldiers.
And through each one
of those situations,
he developed an
increasing empathy.
And he said, fellow
feeling for that.
And the thing that he said,
which is a warning to us today.
He wrote an essay in which he
said that the rock of democracy
will founder at the point
when people of other regions
and classes and
parties and religions
see each other as the
other, rather than
as common American citizens.
So what he did as a leader
was, when he's president here's
a difference again
with President Trump.
He wasn't just stoking his base.
He wanted to expand it.
So he went to states that
he lost as well as states
that he won.
He went to the West as well
as the East on a train.
And he went weeks in the
fall and weeks in the spring.
And he would, and
it was wonderful.
What would have he would meet
with everybody in the city
and he'd hear the
complaints of the press.
He was very close
to the press, which
is another difference
between the two.
They were his
partners in many ways.
And he would then go and
continue on the train.
And he would wave
to people who were
in there, standing in
their small road crossings
along the way.
And there was one point
when he's waving frantically
at a group, and
they're not responding
they're rather cold,
until he's told
because of his nearsightedness,
he's waving frantically
at a herd of cows.
But again, there's
another point.
His Square Deal, he said, a good
deal is when both sides win.
So it's for the rich and
the poor, the capitalists
and the wage workers, I said.
What President Trump has
said is that that's crap,
to say that there's something
about both sides winning.
All that matters
is my side wins.
I mean, literally he wrote that.
So that's the whole
difference in the idea
of what you're
doing in government
and what your leadership
responsibilities are.
ROBIN YOUNG: But when you
talk about him saying,
Teddy Roosevelt saying we will--
who did you say said if
we see the others as--
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN:
That's Teddy, yes.
ROBIN YOUNG: But when you talk
about Teddy Roosevelt wanting,
if we see another American
as the other, we will fail,
do you think the Left has
become as guilty as Trump
and his supporters of seeing
other Americans as the other?
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN:
Well I think certainly
during Hillary's campaign,
that was a problem.
When she was able to
talk about these people
as a whole in a negative way.
Yes, I do.
I mean it's not just the left.
But I think Americans
themselves right now
have to understand other
people's points of view
and why some people feel
that America hasn't been good
for them.
I mean my husband
was writing columns,
Richard Goodwin in the 1980s,
in which he said that democracy
is teetering on the edge of
middle class being squeezed,
and that the Democratic
Party he said then,
was losing goods
sold because it was
too connected to the people
in power, too connected
to the money interests, that it
wasn't worrying about the fact
that plenty of the country
was not being distributed
through the lack of mobility,
through the lack of education,
through the lack of a
progressive politics
reaching down to a whole group
of people who felt they weren't
able to make it through the
system with their discipline
and their energy.
And that was what Lincoln had
always said, that you rise--
what a democracy depends on
its everybody's discipline
and talent can be
used to the extent
that it can rise to the system
as well as they're able to.
And the system wasn't
allowing that to happen.
Yes.
YOUNG: I just want to mention,
when you mentioned Hillary
Clinton, linguists had said--
and this really stuck
with me-- you probably
know this as an observer of
human nature and such a writer.
Linguists have said, she made
a fatal error of saying--
speaking of the basket
of deplorables first.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: Right.
ROBIN YOUNG: And then
she said, of course,
there are wonderful
people who are
truly afraid of their future in
the changing world around them.
And linguists say that
what you frontload with
is all people here.
And if she had
just reversed that,
we might not have had
the reaction that we had.
And you also mentioned
a couple of the things
I want to bring up later.
But talk about how
each of these four men
survived the thing
that burnished them.
It was such
depression for Lincoln
that his friends
removed sharp objects.
It was depression for LBJ
after he lost his first run,
when he went, again,
into a severe depression.
Polio for FDR.
For Ted, it was--
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: Well,
Teddy is the loss of his-- no,
I'd be glad-- wife
and his mother
on the same day
in the same house.
No, you're so right.
I think one of the traits of
a leader that's so important
is resilience and the ability
to come through adversity
and through loss.
And again, if we just talk
about President Trump,
during the campaign,
he said he would
have the very, very best
temperament of anyone who'd
ever run for President
because he had never lost.
He had always won.
Now, of course he had lost.
There'd been bankruptcies,
and if he'd reflected on that,
there might have
been a happy thing.
But in my case-- in my case.
My guys-- so just
going through them,
and here's the interesting
thing about Lincoln.
When he runs for office
the very first time,
he's only 23 years
old and he gives out
this remarkable statement.
He said, every man has
his peculiar ambition.
Even then, he's saying,
mine is to be esteemed
of up by my fellow man--
to be worthy of their esteem.
Amazing that a 23 year old--
most people go into politics
when they're young--
it's for themselves, and
then at a certain point,
it transfers into
for the greater good.
He already had that, right?
Then he says, I don't know
whether I'll win this election.
I'm young and unknown
to many of you.
And if I lose, I've been so
familiar with disappointment,
I won't be very much chagrined.
But then he says,
but if I lose, I
want you to know I'm going to
try five or six more times,
until it will be
too humiliating,
and then I promise
you, I'll never
try again, which means
perseverance was there
from the start with him.
And then as you
suggested, what happens
is he does win the
second time around.
He's in the state
legislature, but his gap
between what his
big ambitions are
and what's happening to him
in the state legislature
are so large that he begins
to feel this melancholy.
And then he breaks his
engagement with Mary Todd
and he feels like he's
broken his word to her.
And he does cycle into the most
serious depression of his life,
where his friends are
so worried, as you say,
that they took all knives
and razors and scissors
from his room.
And his best friend comes
to his side and says,
Lincoln, you must
rally, or you will die.
And he says, I know that, and
I'd just as soon die right now,
but I've not yet
accomplished anything
to make any human being
remember that I have lived.
So that worthy
ambition carried him
through-- that carried him
through two senate losses,
until he finally
wins the presidency.
So that's our Abraham Lincoln.
And then Teddy, as you say--
he was doing well in
the state legislature.
Finally, he'd come
down from realizing
that he had to
change his approach,
and he gets a telegram that
his young wife has given birth
to their first child.
And they celebrate with
cigars, and then he
gets another telegram not
long thereafter saying,
your wife is dying
and your mother,
who'd come to take
care of his wife, who
was only 49 and contracted
typhoid fever, was dying, too.
He goes home.
His mother dies first.
His wife dies the same
day in the same house.
But the incredible thing is
he goes into a depression,
but he goes out to the Badlands
to physically try and recover,
and in the Badlands, he
becomes a westerner-- a cowboy,
as well as an easterner.
And he said he probably never
would have been President
if that hadn't happened.
And so it broadens
his experience.
He's learning about
new ways of life.
When he comes back to politics,
he's a much different man.
And of course, FDR's
resilience through the polio
changed him in lots of ways.
He was an interesting
young man before that.
He had had success.
He was a natural politician.
He found, when he first went to
the state legislature himself--
he said, William
James, the philosopher,
said, every now and then,
your character is defined
when you find that voice
within you that says,
this is the real me.
He found that when
he was barnstorming
the very first time when he went
out for the state legislature,
he wasn't a great
speaker at the time.
Eleanor said they
were so worried
that he would pause so
often between his sentences,
they thought he'd never go on.
But then by the end
of the campaign,
they thought he'd never stop.
He was up there too long.
But then what happens to him,
obviously-- he's in his 30s
still.
He gets stricken with polio.
He's paralyzed from
the waist down,
and he cycles into
a depression, too,
but comes out of it
by just deciding,
I'm going to do everything
I can to strengthen
my back and my chest so that I
can manipulate the wheelchair
and do whatever I can to try
to walk on my own power again.
So every day, he's asked to
be taken from his wheelchair
onto the carpet of
the library floor
so he can crawl for hours,
just to strengthen his chest
and back.
And then, of course,
he goes to Warm Springs
and he allows his
vulnerability to be
seen by the fellow
polios, as they call them,
that he invited
them to come, not
just to heal in
the giant waters,
but to learn to have
fun in life again.
So he plays water polo and tag
and they have wheelchair dances
and they have cocktail
parties at night.
And they wrote-- I read their
oral histories that he changed
their life because he made
them feel they could live
a full life, but he then emerges
much more warmhearted, much
more empathetic to other
people to whom fate
had dealt an unkind hand.
And then, as you say,
LBJ loses a senate race
and goes in the
opposite direction.
Sometimes, adversity
can send you backwards.
He had had much empathy
as a young person before,
but then he turned his
back on the New Deal.
He became more conservative
to win the Senate race,
and then he accumulates
power and he
becomes the majority
leader of the Senate--
the most powerful, youngest
majority leader of the Senate.
But then he has a
massive heart attack,
and then in his
depression, he comes out
and he asks himself,
what if I died now?
What would I be remembered for?
And then even in the Senate,
he goes for civil rights,
gets the first civil rights
bill since reconstruction
through the Senate, and
then, in the presidency,
civil rights becomes
what he cares most about.
So-- Afterwards, some--
ROBIN YOUNG: A
story that you tell
is one I wasn't
as familiar with--
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN:
Yes, of course.
ROBIN YOUNG: I'm sorry.
Not JFK, sorry.
We're in the library.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: We
get our guys confused.
I did that on television today.
ROBIN YOUNG: These
are not my guys.
I don't have that honor, but
you tell the story of LBJ
as a school superintendent
and a teacher,
and buying supplies
for these kids.
Tell that story, because--
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: No.
I mean, it really shows.
When you are able to feel
other people's points of view,
it changes you inside.
So he was in college, and
he had to take a year off
to make money.
So he went to a small
Mexican-American school.
And he said, he saw the pain of
prejudice on these kids' faces.
And he wanted to do
something about it.
So he uses his salary to
buy them sporting equipment.
He's the principal,
the debate coach.
He's the band leader.
He's everything.
ROBIN YOUNG: You almost
feel sorry for them.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: No.
I don't.
Well, they said
he walked so fast,
it was like a blur
going past him.
And, of course, he just
poured that energy into them.
But the really
interesting thing is
so it made him feel-- then he
becomes a young New Dealer.
He brings electricity
to the rural area.
And as I said, until
that first senate loss.
But the amazing thing is,
he returns to that Cotulla
experience in 1965 when the
Selma demonstrations have
brought about the
decision on LBJ's part
to give a speech to a
joint session of Congress.
So on a Sunday night he
decides to give a speech.
Cotulla's going to
be part of this.
And then on Monday
night he's going--
and my husband is
part of this too.
My husband was
working then for LBJ,
doing all of his
civil rights speeches.
And he had to write that
speech, that day, on Monday.
And so Johnson knew not
to bother him all day.
It's the most amazing speech.
"Every now and then
history and fate
meet at a certain time
in a certain place.
So it was at Appomattox.
So it was at
Lexington and Concord.
So it was in Selma, Alabama."
And think about this today.
"This is not a northern problem.
This is not a southern problem.
It's not a white problem.
It's not a negro problem.
It is an American problem.
And we shall overcome."
He took the anthem of
the civil rights movement
and made it theirs, which was
when the outside movement meets
the inside.
That's when real change happens.
But then the only time
he called my husband
not to bother him
that day was, I'd
like you to talk about Cotulla.
And he'd told my
husband this experience.
So Johnson, again,
he said, "I never
thought in 1928 when I
was there with these kids
that I would be able to do
something and have the power
to do something for the sons
and daughters of those kids,
and do something about the
prejudice that they faced
and people are still facing now.
But let me let you
in on a secret.
I have that power now,
and I mean to use it."
It was an incredible moment.
Love that story.
[APPLAUSE]
ROBIN YOUNG: And back
to Donald J. Trump,
because his many supporters
may feel that he is exerting
that same power for them.
They certainly have expressed
that, protecting them
at the border, bringing
back their jobs.
He said today, the
steel industry is back.
And coal miners are working.
Well, of course, we know the
steel industry is not back
and coal miners are not working.
In fact, they're coming
down with black lung again.
But his supporters
strongly feel he is that.
You said something before
about being surprised
that he didn't mention the
losses that his family has had,
the bankruptcies, but also the
lawsuits when his family was
found to actively not
allow African-Americans
to live in their building.
I also think all the time about
the loss of a brother, who
was said to have been the most
charismatic in the family,
and somebody who decided they
wanted to live their own life,
and just charmed the
pants off of every one,
and had all this potential,
and became an alcoholic,
and died of alcoholism.
And here we have a president
who does not drink, but exhibits
a lot of behavior-- tweeting at
2:00 and 3:00 in the morning.
And the loss of a sibling
to me, and as someone
who is familiar with
alcoholism in a family, that
would have burnished me.
That would have shaped me.
As an historian, is that
something that you want?
I know if I ever
interview him, that's
something I've wanted
to ask him about.
DORIS KEARNS
GOODWIN: I mean, you
would hope that
that would bring out
in him that sense
of vulnerability,
the sense of loss, the
sense of self reflection.
And whether it's there and
he doesn't talk about it,
because maybe he'll think
that'll be a sign of weakness,
or whether he just has
shut himself down from it,
I don't know.
Somebody would have to know him.
But I think the
interesting thing
that people feel
he's on their side,
he has certainly mastered
the new form of communication
today, in the social media,
and through his tweets.
It broke through everything.
It makes news wherever he goes.
And each one of my
presidents were able--
I don't really mean to
be calling them "my."
It's just that I've
lived with them so long.
And I wake up with
them in the morning.
I think about them at night.
[LAUGHTER]
And my only fear
is in the afterlife
there's going to be a
panel of all of these guys.
And they're going to tell me
every single thing I got wrong
about them.
And the first
person to scream out
will be Lyndon
Johnson, of course.
How come those damn
books on the Roosevelts
were twice as long as the
book you wrote about me?
[LAUGHTER]
But anyway.
ROBIN YOUNG: He is
the one that you
could say was your president.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: Yeah.
ROBIN YOUNG: Because
you worked for him.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: Yeah.
Exactly.
But even so, so Lincoln
understood at the time
when he was giving
his speeches that,
luckily, his gift for
language was perfectly suited,
because each one of
the speeches would
be printed in full in the
newspaper, and then read aloud,
and reread in country
homes and city homes.
At the time Teddy
comes along, it's
the national newspapers
have just come out.
And so there's a sense
that his colorful language
and his short
statements were perfect.
He made headlines everywhere.
Of course, when FDR is there,
the voice for the radio.
But more than the voice,
it was the intimacy
of his conversational style.
He starts off, "My friends,"
in those fireside chats.
And people feel that he's
really talking to them directly.
There's a story of Saul
Bellow walking down
the street on a hot
Chicago night and watching.
8 out of 10 radios would be
tuned in, more than anything,
more than the entertainment,
the sporting events,
to listen to these
fireside chats.
And he could see people in their
living rooms and their kitchens
looking at their radio.
And he could hear
Roosevelt's voice coming out.
And he said you could keep
walking down the street
and not miss a word
of what he said.
And then there's a construction
worker running home.
And the partner says,
where are you going?
And said, my president's
coming to my living room
to speak to me tonight.
It's only right I be there
to greet him when he comes.
And there was a
sense when he died
that strangers were
huddling around saying,
my friend is gone.
And somebody said,
how incredible
it is that one person dies
and millions feel lonely.
That was the bond that he
established with the people.
And then, of course, you
get JFK and Ronald Reagan
with television.
And LBJ, in those joint
session of Congress,
was able to do that.
And then you get Donald
Trump with social media.
And the difference
is that social media
worked when he was campaigning.
But at some point those tweets
that you do at 2:00 and 3:00
in the morning, those
extemporaneous things
that are not filtered
in any way become
a problem for the country,
cause they're angry.
There's no controlling emotions.
If only he had been able
to do what Lincoln did.
Lincoln, when he
got mad at somebody,
had this ritual where he'd write
a hot letter to the person.
Then he'd put the
letter aside, hoping
he would cool down
psychologically
and never need to send it.
If only he had a hot
tweets and cool tweets,
and he didn't send them out
in the middle of the night.
But because of not making
that gap between campaigning
and governing, not
for some people,
but for all the people--
it's as if Lincoln understood
when he was president that even
though he was able to fight--
he could have had the best
jibes at other politicians.
There's a moment when
somebody yells up
at him in a Stephen
Douglas debate.
"You're two faced!"
And he was able to say,
"If I had two faces,
do you think I'd be
wearing this face?"
He was that quick.
But he said once he became
president he never wanted
to speak extemporaneously.
He wanted to prepare
his words, because he
knew that words matter.
Words inspire.
Words can hurt.
Words can bully.
Words are the
stuff of democracy.
And it's that worries
me the most about now,
that there's no shared
political truth.
But again, I mean--
ROBIN YOUNG: And there are lies.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN:
And there are lies.
And there is fake news.
I understand.
ROBIN YOUNG: It's
been very awkward.
Because the press, and I'm
sure historians debated
for a long time, a lie is
when somebody knowingly
says something.
You can misspeak, or you
could be misinformed.
But when you know that somebody
knows something, it's a lie.
It's very hard to have to say.
But I know you want to
talk about your guys.
But what would you want?
How would you conduct an
interview with Donald Trump?
What would you want to ask him?
DORIS KEARNS
GOODWIN: I think what
I'd do is bring my four
people back and have
them conduct the interview.
ROBIN YOUNG: No.
No.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: No.
I'm serious.
ROBIN YOUNG: What would you say?
What would you say?
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: No.
I mean it.
Just think.
Just think if Lincoln came back.
And he suggested to
him, why don't you
read my second inaugural.
Why don't you read the words
that say, "The sin of slavery
was shared by both sides,"
just on the moment of triumph.
How many times has
President Trump
been on a moment
of triumph when you
hope that the joy of the triumph
will allow him to reach out
to everybody else and not
just this group of people
that elected him?
His inaugural speech
was filled with carnage.
Even at the time of
the Kavanaugh hearings
when he was
triumphant-- he got what
the Republicans wanted, a
Conservative on the Supreme
Court.
And instead of saying,
well, now let's try and heal
these divisions, instead he
said the Republicans were
the good people, and the
Democrats were horrible people
because they'd made this hoax.
At the time of the
bombing plot, I
kept thinking maybe now
he'll be able to say--
and he talked about
unity for a minute.
And then the next
day he was talking
in the opposite direction
that it's the press's fault.
ROBIN YOUNG: Do you mean about
the mail bombing threats?
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN:
The mail bombings.
Yeah.
I mean, that was
the biggest plot
against the country leadership
since Abraham Lincoln.
ROBIN YOUNG: We could have
seen two assassinations.
Of two former presidents.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN:
Just that it didn't happen
doesn't mean that it
wasn't scary to happen.
But I think, to
a certain extent,
the important thing is that--
so if you brought
back Lincoln, he
could talk about reconciliation.
What does he say in
that second inaugural?
He could say to President Trump,
why don't you talk like this?
That "with malice toward
none and charity for all,
let us bind up the
nation's wounds."
The overwhelming number
of people in this country
want these divisions
to be healed.
Right?
If Teddy comes back
he can teach him,
I think, about a deal that's
square for both sides.
If FDR comes back
he can talk to him
about the importance of
establishing a true bond
with all the people
through talking
to them in honest language.
And if LBJ came
back he could say,
let's get the whole Congress
in living in the White House.
And I'm not letting them
out until they come out
with legislation
on infrastructure
or whatever we need.
I mean, LBJ's ability--
what makes me sad is when I
think about what bipartisanship
was like in the 1960s and '70s.
And I think part of
it was, and that's
why I feel somewhat
comfort about the idea
that veterans are
going into Congress,
the reason I think we had such
good bipartisanship in part
was because we had
so many veterans who
had been in World War
II or the Korean War.
And they populated the
Congress and the Senate.
They knew what it was like
to have a common mission
against a common purpose.
No.
A common purpose, and a common
mission across party lines.
And they also lived
in Washington.
They weren't racing
home to make money.
I mean, the money is the
poison in the system.
We can do something about it.
This is what's so important.
FDR said, "Problems created
by man can be solved by man."
There are states
that are now having
a constitutional
amendment started
to reverse Citizens United.
There are states that are
trying, four states now,
to have nonpartisan commissions
draw the congressional lines
instead of the gerrymandering.
I personally have a feeling
that a national service
program would be such a great
binder for us right now.
There are generals that
are talking about that.
What if kids from the
city and the rural area
had host families, and
they worked for a year
in some missions,
disaster relief.
There's so many more people that
want to be in the teacher corps
than the applicants can take.
If we'd spent billions
of dollars on that,
to teach people
to work together--
there are things we can do.
And the reason why I keep
going back to these people
before is because they were
able to accomplish these things.
We have to believe.
If we don't believe we
can change the situation
we're not going to
be able to change it.
We are, though.
I really believe we are.
We're going to.
And this is the beginning
of the awakening.
We have to see this
positive side of what
happened in this election.
ROBIN YOUNG: Well,
and some have said
that some of those
marquee races,
with Beto O'Rourke in Texas,
or the race for the Senate,
or the race for the
governorship in Florida,
it's unbelievable that
the progressives did
as well as they did
in these red states.
And Democrats should
take heart with that.
But your guys are not back.
And I would just die
to be a fly on the wall
if you were able to sit
down with President Trump.
Just one question you'd
want to ask him yourself.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: I
mean, the thing that's
so surprising about
him, but I don't
think it'd be the
question to ask him,
is that I think every
president who's really
been a good president has found
fulfillment in the thought
that what they were doing
was for the greater good,
and that it would be
remembered over time.
I mean, that's what I say.
That's that transition between
the self and the greater good.
And I suppose you'd want to
ask him, what is it that you're
doing that you think
will be remembered
by history in a good way?
And then tell him
in every case it's
the increasing of social
justice or economic opportunity.
Now, he might say
that the economy has
increased economic opportunity.
But it's a short term thing.
And even today he
said, if Obama had
stayed in power we would have
gone downhill economically.
We were already going
uphill at that time.
ROBIN YOUNG: This is a trend.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN:
I guess I don't know
what I'd say to him, honestly.
I'd love to be able to
just talk to him about what
it was that these other leaders
had, what were these qualities,
and to think about whether
he has these qualities.
Ask him, where is the humility?
What kind of mistakes?
He was asked today
about something,
about what did he learn from
the experience of the midterms,
assuming that it was the
House of Representatives,
yes, went Democratic,
and that wasn't so great.
But he said, I learned
that people like me.
That's what his answer was.
[LAUGHTER]
But I guess, so when
I think about it,
humility, empathy, resilience,
controlling emotions.
I mean, what I'm
hoping in some ways,
through reading this book, is
that people, through my having
spent so much time with
him, will just remember
what it takes to be a leader.
My favorite leadership,
unheralded trait actually,
is that they all were able
to find time to think,
and to relax, and
replenish their energies.
I mean, we think we can't
do it in today's world.
And that's one of
the reasons why
it was so helpful
that people came out,
as citizens, because
we feel like we're
so busy with everything.
These guys were pretty busy.
Right?
They had a civil war.
They had World War II.
And yet, they all found time.
Lincoln actually went to
the theater 100 times.
He said when the
lights went down
and a Shakespeare play came
on, for a few precious hours
he could imagine himself
back in the War of the Roses
and forget the war
that was raging.
And, of course, his
greatest form of relaxation
was his extraordinary sense
of humor and his storytelling
ability.
And he was able to make
cabinet meetings that
were really tense and anxious,
undo that tension by telling
a funny story.
Somehow that that's
the way it worked.
I mean, my favorite story that
he always told again and again
that I was able to persuade
Daniel Day Lewis and Steven
Spielberg to put in
the movie Lincoln
had to do with the Revolutionary
War hero, Ethan Allen, who
went to England after the
war to a dinner party.
They decided to
embarrass him by putting
a huge picture of General
Washington in the only outhouse
where he'd have to encounter
it sooner or later.
So they figured he'd be
very irritated at the idea
that George was
hanging in an outhouse.
But he came out
not upset at all.
They said, well, didn't you
see George Washington there?
Oh, yes, he said.
I think it was the perfectly
appropriate place for him.
What do you mean, they said?
Well, he said, there's
nothing to make an Englishman
shit faster than the sight
of General George Washington.
[LAUGHTER]
And he had hundreds,
hundreds of these stories.
And as he said, a
good story could
make him whistle off sadness.
Teddy Roosevelt was able
to exercise every afternoon
for a couple hours.
He had had asthma as a child.
So he had to build up his body.
And he took time off to have
a wrestling match, or a boxing
match, or his favorite was
a hike in the wooded cliffs
of Rock Creek Park.
And he used to
take people along.
And the rule was you couldn't
go around any obstacle.
If you came to a rock,
you had to climb it.
If you came to a precipice,
you had to go down.
So people are falling
by the wayside
as they're trying to be in
the wooded cliffs with him.
But the best story was told
by the French ambassador.
He came in his silk outfit.
He thought they'd be walking
in the Champs Elysee.
And he finds himself
in the woods.
And he's falling down.
And thank god they
reach a stream.
And he said, it's over.
We'll go back.
Then he said, judge
of my horror when
I saw the president unbutton
his clothes, and heard him say,
it's an obstacle.
We can't go around it.
So no sense in getting wet.
So I too, for the honor of
France, took off my apparel.
However, I left on my
lavender kid gloves.
It would be most embarrassing
if we should meet ladies
on the other side.
[LAUGHTER]
So I love these stories.
So then FDR, his is
in some ways the best.
So in the middle
of World War II he
has a cocktail
party every night.
And the rule is that you
can't talk about the war.
You can talk about books
you've read, movies
you've seen, gossip, as long as
the war doesn't get mentioned,
so he, like Lincoln, can
imagine himself in another era.
So after a while this cocktail
party was so important to him
that he wanted the people who
would be going to the cocktail
party to live on the second
floor of the White House
to be ready for
the cocktail party.
So it becomes the most
exclusive residential hotel.
His foreign policy
advisor Harry Hopkins
comes for dinner one night,
sleeps over, and never
leaves until the
war comes to an end.
His secretary, Missy LeHand,
lives with the family
in the White House.
Lorena Hickok, a friend
of Eleanor's, has
a bedroom next to Eleanor.
Princess Martha from
Norway, in exile
in America during the wars,
with the family on the weekends.
And the great Winston
Churchill spends
weeks at a time in
a bedroom diagonally
across from Roosevelt.
So when I was writing the book
about Franklin and Eleanor,
I became obsessed
with the thought.
All these people are
together in their bathrobes
on the corridor that surrounds
the six and seven bedroom
suites.
And just wishing,
when I'd been up there
with LBJ when I was 24
that I thought of asking,
where did Churchill sleep?
Where was Roosevelt?
Where was Eleanor?
But, of course, I wasn't
thinking in those terms then.
So I mentioned this on a
radio program in Washington.
And it happened that Hillary
Clinton, then in the White
House, was listening.
So she promptly called me
up at the radio station,
invited me to sleep
overnight in the White House
so we could wander
the corridor together,
and figure out
through the sleepover
where everyone had slept.
So two weeks later she
invited my husband and me
to a state dinner, after which
between midnight and 2:00 AM
the president, Mrs. Clinton, my
husband and I, my map in hand,
figured out, yes, Harry Hopkins
slept where Chelsea Clinton is
now sleeping.
The Clintons are
sleeping where FDR was.
And we'd been given Winston
Churchill's bedroom.
There was no way I could sleep.
I was certain he was
sitting in the corner,
drinking his brandy, and
smoking his ever present cigar.
But LBJ could not relax.
And that was a problem.
When I was with him
in the ranch later,
when he was still
president actually-- he
had a pool at the ranch.
And you're supposedly swimming
and exercising in the pool.
But it was so filled with
floating rafts, with floating
notepads, and floating
telephones that you
couldn't move in the pool.
Now, he does go play golf.
Whether he's able
to fully relax--
I mean, he said he
would only play golf
if he could persuade somebody
of somebody when he does it.
But I don't see the
joy in this man.
Even when he's had these
moments of triumph,
they turn into fighting
moments about somebody else.
ROBIN YOUNG: You're
talking about Trump.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: I'm now
talking about President Trump.
So I don't see that he truly is
able to find the time to think,
to find the time to really--
ROBIN YOUNG: To reflect.
DORIS KEARNS
GOODWIN: To reflect.
I mean, self reflection is
key, not just for a leader.
For all of us.
And I don't see that in him.
These guys had it.
I mean, FDR took a
fishing trip one day
for 10 days in the
middle of England
being bombed by Germany
before we were in the war.
And while he was
on the fishing trip
he came up himself with
the whole Lend Lease idea,
because he was away from the
bureaucracy in Washington.
And he came up with the idea.
We lend our weapons to them.
We're not allowed to sell them.
We can't give them to them.
But we can lend them.
And then they'll give them
back the end of the war.
ROBIN YOUNG: You're going to
be able to ask your questions
in about 10 minutes.
So be thinking of them.
Another in your list, your
great list of the leadership
traits of these
great four presidents
is the confidence
to surround yourself
with strong-minded people
who can argue and question
assumptions.
And today the president
fired his attorney general.
Well, Jeff Sessions
resigned, as he
said in the letter,
"at your request."
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: I know.
ROBIN YOUNG: Which
I think is a firing.
Of course, this isn't the
first day after the midterms
where there's been a shakeup.
But your sense of
another moment in time.
There's nervousness now.
Outside of the Saturday night
massacre in the Nixon era
investigations, your sense
of another time where people
were so worried that
a president might
try to derail the part
of government that
might be investigating him?
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN:
I mean, I think
the Nixon parallel is
the only one that I
know in our lifetime, again.
But then again, when you think
about where the country was
at when Lincoln came
in, I mean, when
he got elected that first
night, he couldn't sleep.
And he thought, I don't
have enough experience.
I need people around me
who are stronger than me.
And so he put his three chief
rivals into that cabinet,
knowing that they would
all think they should have
been president instead of him.
So that's shoring yourself up.
You have enough
confidence to know
you can put Sewards, Bates,
and Chase in, each one of whom
was better educated,
more celebrated than you.
People said, you're going
to look like a figurehead.
And he said, that's
not a problem, he said.
The country is in peril.
These are the strongest,
most able men in the country.
I need them by my side.
When President Trump
came in, he too
had little political experience.
And there were lots of people
in the Republican Party
who had much more
experience than he had.
But if they had been
never Trump people,
if they had said anything
against him before,
he wasn't willing
to have them there.
So it meant that there's been a
lot of shakeup in the cabinet,
in part because they haven't
had the experience either.
But that's just the
opposite of Lincoln
being able to say,
I want these people,
even though they
were against me,
even though they've
said things against me.
I will somehow forge
them into a team.
And he was able to do that.
ROBIN YOUNG: Yeah.
Again, we're almost to the
questions from the audience.
You have mentioned your fabulous
late husband several times.
And I know a lot of
people probably here--
we're a small town--
probably knew the two of you.
Richard Goodwin.
Extraordinary speechwriter.
You had an incredible
life together.
How are you doing?
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: Well,
it's really been hard.
But the great thing is that
my kids have surrounded me.
And I know that I had
42 years of marriage
with him and 45
years of knowing him.
It was the adventure of a
lifetime to be with him.
He really was an
extraordinary person.
And I can't imagine being
married to somebody else.
And he handled the
last year of his life
so incredibly magnificently.
It made me less afraid
of death, because he
kept wanting to live.
There's no better
sign for somebody.
He was older than I am.
He was 86 years old.
And every day he
fought the cancer,
because he had a book to write.
Because he loved his family.
And he wanted to keep living.
And it's the best tribute,
you can say, to a marriage,
and to him, that he wanted that.
And I will finish his book.
I mean, his book was
about his love affair
with America, the
ideals that he had
wanted to go into public
service with from the time he
was young.
So here he is graduating
from Harvard Law School,
first in his class,
has president
of the law review, clerks
for justice, Frankfurter,
but decides I don't
want to go into law
and just move things around
from one place to another.
He wanted to go
into public service.
So at first he does the quiz
show investigation, which
undoes the $64,000 question.
And then young John
Kennedy is looking
for a second speechwriter.
And he becomes that
second speechwriter.
And the adventure
of a lifetime to be
on that plane with John Kennedy
and Sorensen, and have Kennedy
win the election.
And then he works on the
Alliance for Progress.
And then eventually
he works for LBJ.
And probably that was
the pinnacle of his life,
to be able to really not just
write speeches about the Great
Society, and about civil
rights, but to be helping
to plan those great programs.
But then he has the courage,
when the Vietnam War was
heating up, and
he saw the energy
being taken away from
the domestic program
to leave Lyndon Johnson.
Lyndon Johnson said he would
draft him if he tried to leave.
But, of course, he
was able to leave.
And it's very
important for us today
to see the contrast
between this and what's
happening with people who
know something's wrong
going on, when he left people
inside the administration
said, you know, Dick,
you're hurting your career.
And at least if you leave
you should be quiet.
Don't say anything.
Because you'd be a traitor to
the administration if you did.
But he became active in
the anti-war movement.
And he said things.
And then some of the people in
the administration of LBJ said,
you're cutting your ties.
You're biting the
hand that feeds you.
And then he said,
they didn't feed me.
I fed myself.
I mean, he had such
a sense of humor.
And anyway, then he ends up
working with Bobby Kennedy,
and actually helped Bobby
Kennedy on his Ripples
for Hope speech, the
great South Africa speech.
He was with Bobby Kennedy
when he died, and still
didn't give up on what politics
and public service meant.
With all of those sadnesses of
watching JFK, Bobby Kennedy,
Martin Luther King,
the book he was
writing talked about
the fact that he'd
lived through the Depression.
He'd lived through World War II.
He had lived through
all these events
that happened in the '60s.
And yet, he still believed that
the ups and downs of America
was such that we would
get through this.
One of the last lines was,
"America's not as fragile
as we think."
So it's that hope, I think,
that he gave to me, that I
think he gives to all of us.
And he was the best.
And my son Joey is here.
Oh, Joey.
I'm supposed to
call you Joseph now.
[LAUGHTER]
Sorry.
And Joe carried out that
tradition of public service.
He graduated from
Harvard in '01.
And when September
11th happened,
he volunteered for the army.
And he was a platoon
leader in Baghdad,
and then went back
to Afghanistan.
He earned a bronze star.
And he would say,
and I would say too,
that those were the proudest
moments of his life,
that he was able to bring
a combat troop to safety.
[APPLAUSE]
So I've got Joe.
And he and his wife had
a child this August,
a boy, which is being named
Alexander Richard Goodwin.
So he's living on.
And my son Michael is a teacher
in our high school in Concord
where he and Joe went.
And he and his two
children, who are 8 and 10,
have moved into my
house to live with me.
So there's a whole
generation of the future.
So my husband's alive still.
ROBIN YOUNG: Well
Doris Kearns Goodwin, I
can't wait till you
finish Dick's book, A.
And I wish I had been a
fly on the wall seeing him
in the past.
After 2016 you said that Donald
Trump, as these other men did,
took advantage of
the media of the day.
But I just wish I
could have been there
to see Dick saying, no,
the grammar's wrong.
And it's just not--
responding to those tweets.
Doris Kearns Goodwin.
The book is Leadership.
[APPLAUSE]
And now, we have microphones
in the aisles as usual.
And we're going to have
time for a few questions.
If you have one, please make
your way to the microphone.
I know it's intimidating.
Yep.
We have one over here.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, Doris,
for all you've done for us.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I still think your
best book is about the Brooklyn
Dodgers.
[LAUGHTER]
You've mentioned a
couple of the things that
have happened, unfortunately
in this country
the last couple of months.
But every week is a new
crisis made by the president.
How do we avoid
forgetting about what
happened two weeks
ago when these
are such important events?
DORIS KEARNS
GOODWIN: You know, I
think that's a really
important point you've made.
Because of breaking news--
and think about what happened
three weeks ago with, not only
the bombing plot, but the
Jewish synagogue killings,
and what that meant about
anti-Semitism, the rise of it
in the country, and what we
have to do to combat that.
We were mobilized.
We were thinking we
were going to do that.
And then the next thing happens.
And now it's in the past.
Or the killing of the
journalist, Khashoggi.
And that was such
an important thing
that here's somebody who
represents the press.
And the president's
able to talk about how
it's OK because Saudi
Arabia's giving us
money for the weapons.
And we have to
remember these things.
We can't let the
breaking news let
us forget that there are
really tough moments that
are happening right
now in our country.
And again, only we
can make it better.
Only the citizens
can deal with this.
ROBIN YOUNG: Well,
I was thinking,
I mean, as a journalist
this is overwhelming.
As an historian I hope you
have cards up everywhere,
three by fives.
But I was thinking of
the anonymous letter
to The New York Times about
how the president was being
controlled by people
who understood
that he could possibly run the
government into the ground.
Who mentions that anymore?
And we don't really
even know who that was.
And it's probably forgotten.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: I
mean, I think you're right.
There's an overload right now.
And so one event just collapses
the memory of the other one.
And we just have
to talk about than.
The most important
thing to talk about
is what it's saying about
some of the feelings that
are in the country at large
right now, which we have to,
through education, begin.
I mean, education
is still the key.
And I know that it's so
important here at the Kennedy
Library to have civic education.
And we have to be able to
make citizens again feel
a sense of what the
ideals of the country are.
Lincoln gave a speech
when he was 29 years old,
called the Lyceum speech.
And it's an extraordinary
speech in which
he was worried
then that there was
mob violence in the country.
The antislavery editors
were being killed.
There were lynchings
in the south.
And the rule of law
was not being followed.
This is when we'll arise.
Somebody who will be turning
America upside down who
might be a dictator in like a
Napoleon or a Julius Caesar.
And the answer to
that in a democracy
is we have to make people
read about the ideals
of the Revolution.
He said, he was afraid they were
fading because the Revolution
was now in the past.
And unless those ideals
could be remembered,
what are we going to fight about
this authoritarian figure who's
rising with?
So he said, every
mother should be reading
the ideals of the
Revolution to their kids,
as if they were
reading the Bible.
So again, that's my hope of
what history is, of memory is.
I mean, it's what the whole
Holocaust thing is about.
When people talk
about the importance,
you have to remember
what happened.
We have to remember
what's been happening.
And we have to talk about
how that's not where
the ideals of this country are.
And where is that gap?
And what can we do in education?
What can we do as citizens
to begin to close that gap?
ROBIN YOUNG: Another question.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you so much, Doris,
for your wonderful
insights tonight.
You've accomplished
so much in your life.
Could you share with us
the plans for your future?
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN:
If I knew them,
boy, I'd tell you immediately.
I'm not so sure, to be honest.
What I'm working on for a
little bit of time right now
is some movies.
Because it was such
an extraordinary
experience to work with
Steven Spielberg on the movie.
There's something
about the camaraderie
of working on a movie, and
it happens somewhat quicker
than these long books do.
So hopefully there's
a movie being made.
It's in the early stages,
about Ida Tarbell,
the great female
journalist who was
able to bring down
Standard Oil, and to talk
about the corruption
of Standard Oil
at the turn of the 20th century.
And she's a wonderful figure.
And there's a possibility
I'm working with the History
Channel on a documentary on
George Washington, about which
I know very little.
But that's why it'll be so
much fun to be a consultant
so I can learn about that.
But I'd love to find a woman
that I could write about.
It may not be a woman
president, given that I'm
getting older and older.
But I loved working
on Eleanor Roosevelt.
I mean, that was
such a great pleasure
of the book on
Franklin and Eleanor,
that if I could find another
woman to write about, maybe
not in politics, but in some
field, it would give me,
as a woman, I think,
such pleasure.
I mean, just
knowing what Eleanor
was able to do during that
period of time, I mean,
she really spoke
truth to her husband.
I mean, he said she was a
welcome thorn in his side,
always willing to
question his assumptions.
In fact, much like
we said, she's
the strong-minded person who
was able to argue with him.
She sent so many memos
to General Marshall
about discrimination
in the army that he
had to assign a separate general
whose only task was to deal
with Eleanor Roosevelt's memos.
She had a weekly
press conference
where only female
reporters could come.
So all over the
country, publishers
had to hire their
first female reporters.
An entire generation
gets their start
because of Eleanor
Roosevelt. I'd
love to find that kind of woman
and write a biography that's
not 1,000 pages long.
The Bully Pulpit was so long
that a woman told me that,
in fact, that she was reading it
when she went to bed at night.
And she fell asleep
and it broke her nose.
[LAUGHTER]
So somewhere along the way, I'll
find that woman to write about.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you so much, Doris.
We'll be looking forward to
those future accomplishments.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: Thank you.
ROBIN YOUNG: A
question over here.
AUDIENCE: You suggested
that people who are Trumpers
support him because
they have lost something
or they fear for the future.
But I can't find it
in my heart to think
that those people who believe
in him and who support him
are worth talking to, that
we have anything in common,
that there's anything that could
bridge the divide between us.
Could you give me
some inspiration
to want to become friends
again with people I've
walked away from because of it?
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: I
mean, I think we have to.
We have to understand
that people
who saw their livelihood
going away because the coal
mines were collapsing, or
the globalization of the tech
revolution had taken
away safe jobs that they
had in machinery.
They've seen their
kids not having
an educational
system that's really
been able to support them.
They've seen a lot of their
kids, and not just their kids,
but going into
opioids as a result.
They've watched communities
that have diminished
in their flourishing vitality
because the jobs have
moved somewhere else.
And when you're
in that situation,
the sad thing is, the answer
is not to do what's being done,
to scapegoat other people
for your problems, which
is the voice that
Trump has given them.
It's the immigrants
that are the problems.
It's these people abroad.
Instead of really
talking about the fact
the educational system
has failed them.
Mobility has failed them.
That plenty of America has not
been distributed fairly to them
in terms of what they
get out of the system.
And I think we have to
feel empathy for them.
There's a reason why they are
feeling what they're feeling.
And they're human
beings, like us.
And there's no other
hope than to think.
I mean, that's why that
book Hillbilly Elegy was
so well read, I think, because
it made people understand.
And we have to understand.
Just like you had
to understand--
I mean, the scary thing
that's happening right now--
this will go against
what I'm just saying,
but it's different from it.
I saw a statistic the other
day that more people now
are worried about
their kid marrying
outside the party
than about religion.
AUDIENCE: I would be.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN:
But that's why I think,
if only we could figure
out ways for these people
and what they're feeling
to be understood.
And I think that's where
journalism has to come in.
It's where television
has to come in,
where movies have to
come in, and where
people have to go to these
places and talk to people.
I mean, I was in West
Virginia the other day,
and was talking to a
person whose father was
in the coal mining
industry, and who
felt that that was their life.
They loved it.
Whatever was happening
to their black lungs,
it was their way of life
that was taken away.
And they believed somehow that
it was going to come back.
And I said, but it
hasn't come back yet.
He said, oh, no.
There's a coal plant over there.
And there's machine shops
that are building around it.
And I don't think that's true.
But that desire
to have it becomes
reality for some people.
ROBIN YOUNG: Well, I think, too,
if I might just add just some
of my observations.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: Sure.
Please do.
ROBIN YOUNG: Out on
the campaign trail.
We all know that
there are people
who very much support Donald
Trump who fit that profile.
And I've met them on the trail.
But there are also
people who are
very well off who are
doing quite well who
also support Donald Trump.
And that's where I feel-- and
this is in my conversations--
that this is the
other thing that you
can have some empathy
for, but also progressives
can have some pride with.
It is because there has
been so much change.
There are a lot of people who
it's just almost it's a lot.
And they just either
can't accept it,
or don't know how they
fit in, feel outside of,
don't feel like they're in that
cool crowd of progressives,
however that looks to them,
on late night television.
And all of our culture is
occupied, you'd have to say,
by largely progressives.
And there are people, it's
not that they're in poverty.
It's not that they're
losing their jobs.
It's that they're afraid they
don't know where they fit.
I have felt that a lot.
And yes, I think we
have to be empathic.
I think we have to
start conversations
across the divide.
But that is kind of a tribute
to how much change there's been.
And they're anxious about it.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN:
I think that's right.
ROBIN YOUNG: Yes.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: Thank you both
you ladies for being here.
Doris, put aside a
second the question
of what you would
ask President Trump.
If you had a chance what would
you ask each of your four guys?
Maybe in regards to how
they shaped our lives today,
or maybe making
it better for us.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: Yeah.
I think if I just take Lyndon
Johnson then, for example,
I mean, I had the chance to be
with him in those last years
of his life.
So I was able to
talk to him even then
about the war in Vietnam.
And even though he wasn't
able to acknowledge
that he had made a mistake,
because it was too hard to say
you made a mistake and
50,000 people have died,
he understood that the war had
undercut the thing he cared
about most, the Great Society.
And he knew that I'd been
involved against the war.
In fact, when I won the
White House fellowship
we had a dance at
the White House.
And he did dance with me.
Not that peculiar.
There were only three women out
of the 16 White House fellows.
But it turned out
that prior to my
being chosen as a
White House fellow,
I'd been active as
a graduate student
at Harvard in the
anti-war movement,
and had written an article
with a friend of mine
that we'd sent into
The New Republic,
hearing nothing
until it came out
two days after the dance in
the White House with the title,
"How to Remove Lyndon
Johnson From Power."
[LAUGHTER]
But instead of kicking
me out of the program,
he said I'll bring her
down here for a year.
And if I can't win
her over, no one can.
So I did have that
chance to talk
to him about why he thought
the war was so important.
It was different
from what I thought.
He thought really the domino
theory meant something.
But it meant a lot
to at least hear
his point of view about that.
So that's what I
would have asked him
if I hadn't been able to
talk to him about the war.
And there was such
a sense of knowing
that if ever he were
to be remembered,
it would be for civil rights.
And I think I'd
like him to know now
when you say what would
you want him to know,
I'd like him to know now
which his children know
but he never got to know that
the foundations of so much
of our modern life were set in
those years in 1964 and '65.
Think about it.
Medicare.
Medicaid.
Aid to education.
Civil rights.
Voting rights.
Fair housing.
Immigration reform.
NPR.
PBS.
It's unbelievable.
Head Start.
What a part of our lives
those programs are.
And he deserves to
have that remembered.
And it finally is
being remembered,
even though the war will
always be a challenge to him.
AUDIENCE: And what about the
other three, just quickly?
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN:
Well, I think with Lincoln,
I know I'm supposed to
ask him if I were going
to meet with him, what would
you have done differently
about Reconstruction?
That's the great
historian's question.
But I think if I met with
him, I'd just say, please,
tell me a story Mr. Lincoln.
Cause then you'll come alive.
Your whole face will come alive.
AUDIENCE: That's good.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN:
With Teddy, I
think I'd probably
want to ask him,
if you had to do it
over again, would you
decide not to run against your
great friend, William Howard
Taft, in 1912, which splits
the Progressive Party in two
and allows Woodrow Wilson
to win the election?
And then if you hadn't
run against Taft then,
if you'd only been
able to wait longer,
you probably would have
been able to run in 1916,
and probably would
have been elected.
And how do you feel
about that now?
And I suppose with
FDR, you'd want
to still ask about
the two things that
are the hardest part of his
legacy, the incarceration
of the Japanese-Americans,
and not bringing more
Jewish refugees into the
country before Hitler
closed the door forever.
And you'd want to
try and understand
why were those failures there?
But then, on the other hand,
you'd want him to know,
the New Deal still exists.
So I'd balance it if I
was going to talk to them.
First I'd talk about
the bad things.
No!
First I'd talk about
the good things.
And then I'd talk
about the bad things.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you so much, Doris.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: Thank
you for that question.
ROBIN YOUNG: Question over here.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you very much.
It's an honor to hear you speak.
So given the climate
that we're in today,
I don't want to ask
you who you think
has the best chance to
challenge President Trump.
But what are the
qualities that you
think have to come
through, based
on your research as a historian?
And how would you advise
candidates to best present
those qualities?
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN:
Well, I think
there's a good reason why
the campaign of Beto O'Rourke
captured the imagination
of the country.
Because he decided to go to
every single district in Texas.
He had a progressive message.
He didn't change it.
He got money from small amounts
of money at the beginning.
And there was something
about his authenticity
that captured the
imagination of the people.
And I keep thinking
about the fact
that there was a person in
another midterm election
who lost a senate race.
And that was Abraham
Lincoln in 1858.
But because of the debates
with Stephen Douglas,
he too had captured the
imagination of the country.
He had shown that he could hold
his own more than anything.
Those debates were amazing.
I mean, you think about them,
they were six hours long.
There would be thousands
of people there.
They would be part
of the audience.
They'd be yelling
in, hit him again!
Hit him again!
Harder!
They'd be all part of it.
And the debates
got pamphletized.
They were sent
around the country.
So he became a figure,
even though he'd
lost that senate race.
So I don't know whether
it's Beto O'Rourke.
All I know is that
nobody knew in 1858 yet
that Lincoln would
become Abraham Lincoln.
There's somebody out there.
It may be a mayor.
It may be a city councilman.
It may be some young
person who's lost the race.
Some of the people
who lost these races
were extraordinary people.
And as you said
earlier, Robin, they
ran really close
races in red states
where it wasn't seen to be.
So the unexpected may happen.
And that person will be there.
But I think those
qualities of believing
in what you're saying,
and what Johnson would say
is, what convinces
is conviction.
So he believed in that
cause of progressivism.
He didn't have to change it
when he went from one place
to another.
And that people respected
that, I think, as it happened.
And he worked like hell to
make this thing possible.
And so whether it's
him or somebody else
out there, whether it's one
of the new people coming in.
There's a teacher of the year,
just for the long future, who
is coming in from Connecticut.
First time running.
There's so many
people first time
running who made it this time.
And I think we may
have to just look
for a new generation
of people coming
in for the long
term that are going
to break this fever that's
in Washington right now.
ROBIN YOUNG: I was going to
make a lame Massachusetts
joke that some
people in this room
were hoping you would
say the qualities
of a presidential candidate
would be, she's a senator--
You set with your--
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Very much.
ROBIN YOUNG: Thank you.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: My question
is somewhat like hers.
This country's been
blessed over the years
to have extraordinary
people come along
during very troubled times.
And I'm wondering under
the circumstances of today,
the extreme diversity, the
way politics runs itself,
is there someone out
there that could do this?
Or do you think
something else might
be the spark that
brings us back more
towards where we used to be?
DORIS KEARNS
GOODWIN: Well, we got
to hope that the spark is
not some military crisis.
Cause crises from abroad
sometimes do bring us together.
But that's why I keep
thinking that somehow we
do have a crisis right
now in the country.
The crisis is that our
political system is not working.
I mean, it's not working
to produce any kind
of collaboration in Washington.
It's not working to
solve the problems that
are real problems
that are out there.
And to the extent
that it's a crisis,
that usually does
produce people.
So far we've seen that happen.
You're right.
And the interesting thing
is, each one of these four
presidents that I've
studied might not
have been the right
person for the other time.
And when you have a crisis
and you have an opportunity,
it doesn't mean
you're going to always
have the right person there.
I mean, Buchanan was
there before Lincoln
when the country was
already splitting apart.
And yet, he escalated
the divisions
before Lincoln came along.
In fact, Buchanan
used to be the lowest
on the presidential
historians' polls.
And in the latest
presidential historian poll
a few months ago, he
was no longer the last,
because President Trump
was at the bottom.
So there was a story
in the newspapers
that the Buchanan family
ancestors were celebrating.
He was no longer at the bottom.
[LAUGHTER]
Or think about Herbert
Hoover, the president
was there when the
Depression had started.
And he was a decent, good man.
But his ideology could
not allow himself
to believe that the
federal government had
to step in to deal with the
jobs, to unrig the system.
And so he was then undone.
And FDR was the right person
with that contagious optimism.
So we have had those
people at the right times
at the right places.
And it's interesting.
Teddy Roosevelt
said it one time.
"Can you really be a great
president without a war?"
Thinking that you needed what
your question is suggesting,
a crisis to mobilize
people around.
But he understood
the hidden crisis
of the time, which was
the inequalities created
by the Industrial Revolution,
and the big companies
swallowing up small companies.
And he dealt with that.
And that's why he's in the top
of those presidential ranks.
So yes.
I do still think there's
got to be somebody
who can bridge those gaps.
It's not somebody, whether
the person's black, or white,
or Native American, or
whatever they come from.
It's that human quality that
they can contain other people
within themselves, and that
they can empathetically
look at the country, and
somehow make the country
feel that we want to be
common citizens again.
We want to believe that
we're moving forward.
And there's lots
of stuff that still
has to happen in this country.
As I say, education.
I mean one of the great
things that's happening--
our teachers more.
The fact that we don't
give them higher salaries.
value what they're doing
with our citizens is crazy.
And the educational
system is at the bottom.
That's what Lincoln believed,
that the educational system was
critical toward a democracy.
So we have so much
to do in education.
We have so much to
do in economics.
There's problems
that are out there.
We have so much to do to
bring the immigrant situation
to a citizenship
that we need to do.
Those real problems,
somebody's going
to talk about the real
problems in a way that's
authentic, and unexpected.
So someone's out there.
I promise.
Maybe they're here.
Maybe it's one of you guys.
ROBIN YOUNG: I think we
have time for the last three
questioners, who are
here, if we're concise.
AUDIENCE: I will be concise.
Thank you so much.
In my opinion, you're
an icon in terms
of historical perspective.
I mean, you write about it.
You've lived it.
And thank you for giving
us some hope in a time that
sometimes seems like despair.
The first question's
an easy one.
I have two.
They'll be quick.
I know you're a baseball fan.
So how do you like our Red Sox?
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN:
Oh, I'll tell you.
It made this summer
so extraordinary.
I mean, again, look
at what sports does.
Sports combines people
across party lines,
across racial lines.
It's a common thing
that people can
talk about that connects them.
It combines people in families.
Certainly my own love
of sports occurred
because my father
taught me to keep score
when I was only six years
old so I could record
for him the history of that
afternoon's Brooklyn Dodger
game.
So when this World
Series came, it
was my first love, the
Brooklyn Dodgers, and then
my enduring love, the Red Sox.
So the only thing it
made me think about was I
sort of felt empathy
for the people
in Los Angeles who hadn't
had a World Series victory,
only to the point where I
hoped it would go seven games,
and then the Red Sox would
win in the ninth inning
of the seventh game.
But what an extraordinary
thing it is.
I mean, that team.
I still haven't gotten into my
head that in the 21st century
we've won four championships.
There's still that old
lingering feeling of we're
going to screw it up in
the end, because we always
did that before.
And that's what I
was beginning to feel
in September and October.
I don't know that anything
will ever counter, however,
what it felt like in 2004.
After all those years.
I remember in one of
the playoff games,
when we lost the year before,
and some old guy stood up.
And we're all so desolate.
And he just says, year,
after year, after year.
And we all started laughing.
We felt this sense
of connection.
But it's a nicer
thing when you win,
rather than when you lose
to feel the connection.
So it's great, the Red Sox,
what they've done for us.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
This question's a
little bit deeper.
We are going through,
as we've all mentioned,
some very difficult times.
We have a president that, after
the shootings in Pittsburgh
where 11 people were massacred,
and then 14 bombs were
distributed, which could have
killed two former presidents,
as well as several
people around them,
we have a president
that was upset
because it broke his
momentum during the election.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN:
And he said that aloud.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
He also considers
himself a nationalist.
And we are also facing,
I think, in the world--
we have countries like
Italy that are going
through populist revolutions.
And, again, I've, of course,
read all of your books.
But I just finished
Madeleine Albright's book,
Beware of Fascism.
And it appears that
not only domestically,
because our president
has alienated
so many of our partners
around the world,
but internationally
there are undercurrents
of what might have happened
before World War II.
What do you think,
or how close do
you think we are, as
a world, approaching
a catastrophic event?
And what has to happen
in the United States
for us to pull back our civility
and come to the middle again?
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: Yeah.
I mean, I do think that when
you see echoes of what's
happening here in
other countries,
there's some awareness that
there hasn't been attention
in any of those other
countries to distributing
the wealth and the
power of the country
to large numbers of people.
Again, all those countries
have these huge gaps
between the rich and the poor.
And I just keep thinking
about, there was a moment
after the wall fell
when I remember
there was an article in Time
magazine about how democracy is
spreading all around the world.
It was one of those
halcyon moments,
where you felt that somehow
democracy was on the rise,
and that authoritarian
governments like the Soviet
Union were breaking apart.
And now it feels
the opposite way
through the world as a whole.
And maybe it does have something
to do with globalization.
Maybe it does have something
with big companies.
to do with that the people have
not been able to get the
fruits of the prosperity
of their nation.
But I guess in the
end, the ultimate check
on any of that are the people.
I mean, we were
worried about where's
the check for the
Congress, and the Supreme
Court, and the presidency?
Well, now there is a
check that's in place.
We've made the first check with
the House of Representatives.
And, in the end, if
the people themselves
begin to really think
through what we've all
been talking about tonight, I
think the overwhelming majority
of the people, they don't
want to see immigrants undone.
They don't want
to see the things
that we're talking about.
They really want to have a
solution to these problems.
They want to see
healing division.
They don't want this
to be happening,
this increasing polarization.
So we just have to find answers.
And maybe the answers are small.
And maybe it's going
to start in the states
before it goes to the
federal government.
I mean, the states used to be
the laboratories of democracy
in the progressive era.
So now they're going
to have to be fighting
against what's going on.
And they have to
be changing laws
in the cities and the states.
There's problems in
each one of those areas.
That somehow there's
less divisiveness in some
of those local areas.
But we just have to just
take it one step at a time.
And one step was taken.
Or maybe many steps
were taken yesterday,
not only in the House,
but I think, as I say,
in people still willing
to enter public life,
knowing what it's about, knowing
that your private life is
going to be exposed.
You don't even
have to raise money
too much, knowing that
it hasn't been very
fulfilling for many people.
But they still
wanted to come in,
and they wanted to change it.
So those are the moments
that we have to take.
There's no other choice but us
to take the sense of positivity
and move it forward
step by step.
And hopefully people
in other countries--
Brexit.
All these things
are echoing here.
They've got to do it in
their own countries as well.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
ROBIN YOUNG: And we
have two last questions.
AUDIENCE: It's just a follow
up question on the Vietnam War.
I've watched the
Ken Burns series,
and also read the John Lawrence
book, The Cat From Hue.
But at so many junctions
LBJ could have pulled us out
of that war.
And it was so evident it
was an unwinnable war.
What do you think was
going through his mind?
And why didn't he exit us
from that terrible tragedy
when he had so many
opportunities to do it?
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: Yeah.
I mean, the really
sad thing is that when
you hear the tapes, those
tapes that are now published
of his conversations
in early '63, '64, he
himself was wondering what
are we doing over there?
It wasn't that he
was a person who
saw a vision of our
being able to succeed
in any way over there.
It was that he didn't want to
fail, so that he's presented
with a situation, if you
don't send this many troops,
then it looks like
it's going to be lost.
And that'll mean the
Democratic Party has lost,
just like they lost China.
And it's going to be a
terrible thing for the country.
It'll be a failure for you.
So when your whole leadership
is based on not losing,
rather than what
are we doing there?
What's the vision?
What could be the victory there?
Then you just keep escalating
the troops, little by little,
as he did.
And worse than that, you
don't tell the public
exactly what you're doing.
So you put in the
extra appropriations.
You don't have a new tax
that you should have.
You don't call up the reserves.
But then there were
consequences then.
I mean, the fact that
he wasn't telling
the truth about the war, that
he was presenting it as better
than it really was, that's what
led to his loss of credibility,
the credibility gap.
It led to his having to
resign from the decision
to run again in 1968.
So there were consequences for
that kind of action before.
That's what's the
contrast with today.
There have to be consequences
for what's going on.
But I think all it was just
an epic failure of leadership.
He was so good domestically.
He wasn't comfortable
in foreign policy.
He thought if he could
bring a Mekong River Delta
project to Ho Chi Minh that he'd
be willing to bargain his way,
and somehow end the war
because of the goodness
that we'd bring, like he brought
electricity to rural Texas.
He just wasn't suited for that.
And then put in
a situation where
it meant possible failure,
he kept going forward.
It would have been hard
for anybody to pull out.
I mean, that has
to be understood.
I mean, it would
have meant possibly
a lot of recriminations, because
we would have seemed to be--
But it might not have even
meant a loss earlier on,
like it finally became anyway.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: So it's a
very sad moment in our history.
And it's important
to remember that too,
just to teach us what we're
doing in foreign policy
right now.
AUDIENCE: And we have
one last question.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN:
The final question.
Dum da dum dum.
AUDIENCE: I just want to take
you away from Donald Trump,
and go back to 1947 where you
were a young girl in Brooklyn.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN: OK!
AUDIENCE: And you
wrote your first book,
and told your dad that you were
going out with your girlfriends
for the night.
And you got home late.
And your dad says,
where were you?
And you say, dad, I've
got a confession to make.
I know I'm not supposed to
go to a Protestant Church.
But he says Jackie Robinson
and Roy Campanella were down
at the Baptist
church and I went.
And he says, why the
hell didn't you tell me?
[LAUGHTER]
ROBIN YOUNG: That's
a great story.
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN:
In fact, let me end.
I'm so glad you let us end on
a note other than Mr. Trump
right now, because
we need to just enjoy
something else about ourselves.
So the fact that I was
brought up as a Catholic
did conflict with my love
for the Brooklyn Dodgers,
not only because I had to go
into this Protestant Church
and was afraid that
I might be giving up
the life of my everlasting
soul for this one night
to see a Brooklyn Dodger person.
And as I crossed
the threshold, I
thought maybe this
is what I'm doing.
So I thought I had
to confess this
in my first holy confession
when I went to get my communion.
So I told the priest that
I'd done this, that I'd
gone to this Protestant Church.
And it wasn't a problem.
We were sitting
on folding chairs.
It was talking
about sportsmanship.
It had nothing to
do with religion.
So it's not a sin, he tells me.
But then he said, and
what else, my child?
And then I had to confess
another sin that related
to the Brooklyn Dodgers.
So I tried to hide it in between
talking too much in church,
wishing harm on others,
being mean to my sister.
And unfortunately
the priest said,
to whom did you wish harm?
And I had to admit that I wished
that various New York Yankee
players could break their
arms, legs, and ankles
so that the Brooklyn Dodgers
could win their first World
Series.
So he said, how often do you
make these horrible wishes?
Every night, I said,
when I say my prayer.
So he said, look, let
me tell you something.
I love the Brooklyn Dodgers too.
And I promise you, you don't
need to wish harm on others
to make it happen.
It will happen someday.
Then he made me say
a bunch of prayers.
And then as I left the
confessional booth, he said,
say a special prayer for
our Brooklyn Dodgers.
How lucky that my
first confession was
to a baseball loving priest.
[LAUGHTER]
ROBIN YOUNG: Look, I
will only add to that.
I'm looking at this list of
all the leadership traits.
And they are an ability
to go through loss.
Empathy.
Resilience.
A confidence to
surround yourself
with people who
will question you.
Controlling impulses
and negative emotions.
Ambition for self ambition
for the greater good.
And I'm thinking, this
can apply to all of us.
We don't wait for a leader.
I think, as Americans,
we have to reach a--